[Music]
welcome to the uplift we've got a great
show for you a great cast of characters
as well among them these a dog traveling
across the world on the back of a
motorcycle got the goggles on we like
that also a young scientist she's nine
years old honored by Yale University the
ivy league what did she do to deserve
that recognition we will get into it
also a man who gave up a job at a desk
for a sled with a lot of dogs there they
are and a man building something just
absolutely massive in his own backyard
some call it a wild dream and still he's
chasing it all that and more
heartwarming videos ones you just need
to see on the uplift
[Music]
hey there I'm Tony decopo and this is
the uplift the show that lifts you up
for at least the next 30 minutes you at
home and me as well here in the studio
we're going to begin with a pair of
Roommates who found each other in a
unique way Caitlin O'Kane has their
story last year Askari Johnson found
himself starting fresh he was released
from San Quentin prison after more than
20 years and he had several goals for
his new life one was to live
independently in nearby Oakland Tyler
jenk was looking for a roommate to share
his house he connected with ascari
through a unique program called the
homecoming project the homecoming
project is a program to place formally
incarcerated people into homes that are
potentially a better situation than
halfway houses the program pays their
rent and gives them a laptop and a cell
phone and guidance to help get started
back in society ascari is a carpenter by
trade and took courses at San Quentin to
help prepare for his release it was his
lawyer who told him about the homecoming
project it fit the goals that I set for
myself while I was in prison I kept in
touch with a lot of people that was that
had parole prior to me and so I really
live vicariously through their lives the
ups and downs The Good The Bad and The
indifferent
and so
um having that experience living through
them it helped me prepare for my success
even more despite coming from different
walks of life the pair had things in
common when you meet somebody you get a
vibe from either it's good or bad or
someone in between and it was just a
good vibe we had a good sense of humor
about the whole situation the interview
went well I mean it was just natural
he's in construction I'm in construction
so we had that in common we like sports
so it was like a match made in heaven so
to speak another thing they had in
common cooking but he tried it toddler
doesn't know this so he likes to cook
and I like to cook
but I'll be kind of embarrassed for
people to taste my cooking like so there
was a couple of times when I cooked
something out and I came this close to
offering and I was like nah he tasted I
don't like it I wonder how you gonna
tell me the truth or say no it's good
the back room was spitted out the
program is run by impact Justice and
funded by Wells Fargo impact Justice
says formally incarcerated people are
almost 10 times more likely to become
homeless than the general population
providing a safe space for ascari was a
simple way for Tyler to give back feels
good to to help so you know happy happy
to help and like like I said a scar I
didn't need too much help but being in
construction you know he would ask
questions he could ping ideas off me job
opportunities what unions uh what he
what I thought about
um his job opportunities and kind of
kind of helped out escari landed a job
as a contractor within two months of
joining the homecoming project he's
moved out of Tyler's place and he's
looking for a home of his own
so this whole saying preparation meets
opportunity equals success right so I've
been prepared for this
seriously like the last seven years of
my incarceration in the soul when I came
home people ask that question all the
time what does it feel like and I always
said it felt like I I never left it was
a great stepping stone to reach the
Pinnacle of My Success whatever person
you know defines success as but um yeah
I wouldn't I couldn't have written a
better scrub even though ascari and
Tyler are no longer roommates the impact
of their time together is lasting like
Tyler opened up his heart right but more
importantly he opened up his home right
just to a stranger and I think if more
people had that ability to just expand
their thinking just explore it I think
of the help of society enormously
we all have it we don't use it enough
Great Piece there moving on to our next
one an introduction to a German Shepherd
traveling the world with the goal of
helping women she's doing it all on the
back of a motorcycle as well here's
Jamie Lucas with the story
foreign
for more than 300 travel days Moxie and
her owner Jess Stone load up their bike
get their goggles on and start cruising
the open road
75 pound Moxie isn't in a sidecar or
trailer and that often catches the eye
of other drivers what is the reaction to
moxie on the back of the bike people are
almost going to get into an accident
when they see her
we caught up with The Thrill Seekers in
Los Angeles this week as they Trek
across the country
then it's off to South America Africa
Europe and Asia this is more than just
an adventure how did you decide to do
this I wanted a bigger impact so I was
thinking well let's ride around the
world together and I wanted to do it for
a good cause so I had my eye on the
non-profit girl up for a long time and
they do leadership and development
training for girls in 130 countries the
United Nations founded girl up in 2010
dedicated to encouraging and training
young women to be leaders it really
spoke to me and I always think about the
fact that if I had that when I was
growing up I feel like I'd be a lot
further along in my life first time on a
motorcycle the Journey started last
March but Stone learned how to ride 11
years ago in Africa with her husband
Greg as her teacher it was very anxiety
provoking I'm the only female riding and
I have that feeling like people are
watching and thinking why is she riding
she doesn't know how to ride but soon
after
he was hooked and the couple did their
first eight month long motorcycle ride
together making their way across North
and South America until finding a new
home in Guatemala here we have our new
puppy that's where they first met moxie
girl
looking to get back on the road with
their new best friend they developed the
canine Moto cockpit the three now go
roughly around the world I just like
being able to share it with my whole
pack and we get to go together but
you're the leader I'm the leader you're
the leader of this pack yeah 100 I do
not like being in the back I want to be
the one who goes through the obstacle
first
obstacles like a herd of bison and a
bike Crasher too and while it takes guts
to glide through to far-flung places we
made it to the Arctic Ocean or Malibu's
famous Canyon roads Stone says she gets
her fearlessness from her furry sidekick
if it was just me I would just have my
helmet on and wouldn't want to really do
with anybody else but by having her she
really puts us into the spotlight I just
feel like they always say man's best
friend but she's really
she's really a woman's best friend at
this point in time she is I named her
Moxie because I felt like I needed some
Moxie in my life she's not scared of
anything and it's something that I
needed in my life because it was
something that I struggled with as well
so she inspires you 100 and now can
Inspire others hopefully yes as the
saying goes in life it's not where you
go but who you travel with I'd say for
these three it's also about who gets to
benefit from the journey
the answer is we all do thank you Jamie
coming up meet the man with a dream that
some called wild but with a little
encouragement from others it's a dream
that is coming true
it was always what about significant
other what about kids what about career
what about what about what about what
about yeah I am and then we would talk
to people who are in their 70s their 80s
they would go to it you have this dream
go do it what are you waiting for
plus a shocked four-year-old there she
is what's on her mind we'll tell you
after the break
welcome back to the uplift we now have a
heartwarming video for you it shows
four-year-old Emery who knew she was
going to be having a new brother or
sister she got a big surprise when her
mother showed her a sonogram
oh
the baby surviving it is a lot
this is the baby
you want to know why it's a lot yeah why
I'm gonna tell her
because the baby's so big and there's
two babies
a brother and another brother a brother
and a sister
mm-hmm
this is
[Music]
we rather
um baby sister
I can't believe it I didn't know what's
gonna I do
time over it
[Laughter]
all right that is adorable that might be
the most heartwarming of heartwarming
videos we have ever showed on this
program uh I guarantee it all right
coming off a nine-year-old girl set out
on a passion project that earned her
widespread attention and an invitation
from Yale we're gonna top ourselves plus
a Minnesota man decided to take a new
career path and that path required a
sled
[Music]
time now to introduce you to a man from
Minnesota who gave up a job at a desk to
build a team of rescue dogs here's CBS
Minnesota's John lawrenson with his
story
on a clear crisp winter morning the
girls commands like ha NG echo through
the winter air stay hot
good girls for these Siberian Huskies
those words mean left and right and it's
all the encouragement they need during
the dog days of winter
[Music]
as soon as I pull those snow hooks pull
the anchors the quick release we're off
and running you don't hear a sound out
of them all right hike
[Music]
Jack Christopher is the owner of Silent
run adventures and the leader of this
pack he gave up a desk job for a sled I
much rather do this in companionship oh
we didn't forget you I built my first
dog team basically out of rescues
they're very friendly they do great with
people some of them are a bit shy
just not when they're ready to go yeah
put her in the second spot there
now has 26 Siberians some weigh 80
pounds or more all right hey come on
Hike It Up
strength and durability allow them to
track through Arctic conditions though
this team spends much of its time on
Minnesota lakes the number one mushroom
rule is always dogs first so they always
get watered and fed before I do Jack has
plenty of help with that this is my guy
rocket he is a rescue I rescued him back
in March Stephanie Dreyer is a
self-proclaimed emotional support human
for the dogs the bond that we're making
working together
out on the sled is it's something else
the girls proof that the phrase Man's
Best Friend applies even on the frozen
tundra I wanted to see how much the dogs
love what they're doing they get very
excited to go
does he not miss his indoor desk job
just a little bit I guess not it's a
sweet story lovely dogs as well moving
on to our next story a nine-year-old
girl from New Jersey recently found
herself with a very unique Hobby and it
earned her national attention and
recognition from the Yale University
here CBS New York's Bradley Blackburn
it has red and brown wings with black
spots and nine-year-old Bobby Wilson can
tell you exactly what it is
last fall she learned about this
invasive species in school and wanted to
help she found a bug spray recipe on
tick tock
my mix water dish soap and apple cider
vinegar she was using it outside her New
Jersey home when a neighbor called the
police a little black woman walking and
spraying stuff on the sidewalks and
trees I don't know what the hell she's
doing scares me though Bobby's mom says
it was racial profiling those exact
words in another town another state
I could be grieving Yale University
assistant professor ijoma opara heard
Bobby's story and decided to take this
young entomologist under her Wing oh
yeah Bobby belongs here Bobby isio she
invited Bobby to campus to meet
scientists who look like her
[Applause]
on Friday Bobby was back to see the
first spotted lanternfly specimens added
to the Yale Peabody Museum of Natural
History collection those insects were
gathered by Bobby herself how does it
make you feel to know that these bugs
are going to be in this Museum
happy and proud a young girl who's
flying high and now has the bug for a
career in science
she's feeling happy and proud we're
feeling happy and proud as well that's a
lovely piece Bradley thank you very much
when we come back he was told his dream
was wild but that has not stopped him
from following it what was he creating
we'll tell you
[Music]
there are backyard projects and then
there's this from a man in Massachusetts
working on something truly massive in
his backyard it's taken him seven years
he knew it would be a feat given he's
never built anything at all before but
nothing has stopped him from following
his dream what was he building Brooke
Silva Braga shows us
you can see what really what we've been
building
wow
I mean it looks like a boat it looks
like a boat yeah and every stage of the
process that's what people say ah it
looks like a boat oh it finally looks
like a boat oh now it looks like a boat
when the process started Steve Dennett
knew nothing about boat building but
making one from scratch he estimated
back then would take him as much as 10
years when we first started and I was
like I'm gonna cut down the trees and
build a boat and everyone's like you're
crazy and it was always what about
significant other what about kids what
about career what about what about what
about what about yeah yeah and then we
would talk to people who are in their
70s their 80s they would go to it you
have the stream go do it what are you
waiting for do you think it's because
they couldn't do it anymore or because
why do you think the difference in the
generations I think they understand what
a lifetime is and what you actually have
the time for and what you're going to
look back on and wish you had or hadn't
done
so in January 2016 Dennis so that guy's
a white oak with no gray in the beard
yet started cutting trees how was that
it was good that was good made Splash
his friend Alex creeder agreed to help
and make videos how did they go today
it went when it was done they'd go
sailing together
Creator filmed as the logs became boards
and as those oak boards were steamed
down she goes until they could be bent
into their new shape you have a matter
of minutes to get them bent into the
boat before they Harden and become
non-playable again and then you just
fire in the are they rivets or rivets
yep so there are square copper rivets
and we couldn't find them big enough
anymore we made a machine to make the
rivets
plan to fund the project was for Creator
to make these videos to drum up
donations through a crowdfunding site so
the first Keel bolt is in and yesterday
we bolted up the stem here but for a
long time the money didn't come for two
years Dennis and creeder had to keep
their day jobs and scrounge for supplies
for the lad we needed 12 000 pounds
total where do you find 12 000 pounds of
lead you hunt for a year and a half so
where do you go hunting for lead I
literally would ask every single person
that I had a conversation with do you
know where I can get some lead hold on a
second if you ask a hundred people that
question how many have a positive answer
for you one or two
well sometimes you strike gold or lead I
talked to a woman and her daughter and
they're like actually yeah my husband
has a tire shop so we went and picked up
2 000 pounds of wheel weights figuring
out how to pour our own Keel has been a
trying part of this project the video of
melting that lead and pouring it into a
keel went viral on YouTube and acorn to
Arabella caught on donations in YouTube
add money let Dennett and creeder quit
their jobs and build full time the
attention also brought more and more
help paid and mostly unpaid people like
Dennett drawn to doing something exotic
and hard for reasons they struggle to
fully explain KP polella was supposed to
start college but took a job here
instead that's it the confusing part is
you had already tried boat building well
I love boat building but then you left
boat building correct because it didn't
pay enough that's right but this pays
much more than that no so that's where
I'm trying to understand that's fair
that's fair it's going to start coming
down a little bit okay nine-year-old
Aaron Wayans volunteers every Friday
I'll try my hardest this was his first
time using a Disc Sander
76 year old Joe Damon arrived with four
Decades of experience on the Bridgeport
machine that happened to be donated just
before he came by how do you find out
about this my wife spotted it she sits
in Granby I said our Granby or Granby
Connecticut she says no Granby Mass
went out and jumped in my truck and came
over how long ago was this
six years something like that you've
been coming here for six years
yeah
those years haven't just transformed the
wood but the people working it Creator
is about to be a married dad he's
already helping take care of his own
father he won't be voyaging with denim
put our hearts and souls in this
together for a long time and then to
have them step away is definitely hard
but you know I think he made the right
choice for sure but as he'd been warned
Devotion to the Arabella did make it
hard for Dennett to find love all of the
time building the boat I don't think any
woman was past like two dates before
they were like yeah I don't see myself
on a boat like I'm stepping out of this
one that is until he met Robin Agricola
who had already been hoping to explore
the world from a camper van and I was
like yeah you know what I'm like live
this nomadic lifestyle and he's like I
see your van and I raise you a 38 foot
wooden sailboat if all goes is planned
they'll launch the boat in June it's a
small Cozy home though Dennis won't
Captain it at least at first pallella
will thanks I'm not a sailor I don't
come from that background we've skipped
over this haven't we we have yeah your
sailing background is non-existent at
all yeah never sailed I maintained the
first boat I sail on I'll be the one I
built
I sure hope you'll like it I know you've
heard that but you know I'm sure hope
you like it I do too and I think I will
and honestly if I don't I've learned so
much building the boat I have grown so
much I've met such amazing people and
connections and even if I hated sailing
I I would not regret any of this no
regrets that is our show this is your
life I hope we just brighten it up a
little bit brightened up my day I'm
gonna go look for some good news you
should as well see you next time
[Music]
thank you